Nixon and Ford Secretary of State Henry
Kissinger in his new book the flawed
architect this public lives feature is
an hour and fifteen minutes it's it's
very nice to be back here I remember
last time I was at GW was actually a
very different location much much much
improved I must say from from the
previous occasion and I'm really
delighted to to be here today
both to to see a lot of friends that I I
met here when I spend my year at the
Woodrow Wilson Center and of course to
talk a little bit about Henry Kissinger
a book that has been in progress for on
and off for about seven years which
seems like a half a lifetime actually
but there we are these things take time
anyway I thought I would begin today and
what I'm going to do when I was talking
to people I said I'm going to give some
talks about my book and they look at the
book and it's it's rather thick and they
said well just try not to be boring and
I said well I'm from Finland so I'm
boring and therefore they suggested that
I should have something for people to
look at while I talk about talk about
Henry Kissinger and so I'm going to do
this PowerPoint presentation and I hope
it works and show particularly some
interesting cartoons and other other
illustrations just to highlight some of
the points in the book and the first one
I chose is actually a very recent one
this is from December of 2002 and I
thought it appropriate to begin with
this because Henry Kissinger who left
office in early 1977 has been in the
news pretty much ever since he left
office and he's always been
controversial and one of the latest
controversies had to do with the 9/11
Commission and 9/11 of course we we had
the anniversary just three days ago
in this particular cartoon and many of
you of course know that when the 9/11
Commission was set up the initial
chairman of the of the Commission was to
be Henry Kissinger it turned out that he
did not choose to remain as the chairman
of the Commission and I think this this
cartoon here illustrates some of the
reasons why he chose not to do that and
as you can see there Church W Bush
pointing out that after nominating
Kissinger Keys dr. kitchen is already
uncovering some skeletons in the 9/11
closet and advisor whispering to him
that in fact that's dr. Kissinger's
closet and there of course are many many
skeletons in dr. Kissinger's closet and
some of the more obvious one are
indicated obvious ones I indicated their
clandestine environment with Pinochet
the Chilean dictator also been quite a
bit on the news recently wiretapping
kissing his famous for wiretapping his
own staff secret consultancy contracts
that refers to something that comes
after he leaves office and secret
bombing of Cambodia one of the things
that asks one of these is created a
great deal of controversy about Henry
Kissinger
for the last three decades and more so
obviously he is not yesterday's news in
this sense and I think that is something
something too
one of the reasons why I think I
initially decided to actually study
Henry Kissinger the other reason is that
there is a great deal of the two
different almost polar opposite views
about ten occasions that I discovered
when I started getting really interested
in in the man and in his career in in
the Foreign Office he is an American
icon he is a great American success
story
a man who has a fifteen-year-old moved
from Germany to escape the persecution
of Jews in Germany came to the United
States in 1938 was later naturalized he
actually returned to Germany during the
war as part of the American occupation
forces and then went to Harvard
eventually got his PhD published
numerous books became a professor of
government at Harvard and of course then
eventually joined the Nixon
administration initially as a national
security adviser and in 1969 then in
September of 1973 of course became also
the Secretary of State becoming the only
man to hold those two offices at the
same time for more than two years and
Kissinger likes to joke there's never
been a period when the relations between
these three offices have been better
than in 1973 75
he also made obviously became a great
celebrity he became I guess what you
could call a diplomatic rockstar he was
always in the headlines he seemed to
hold the world in the palm of his hand
juggling many many issues at the same
time and here we see Henry the juggler
in one of the cartoons from 1974 when
his fame is really at the height this is
in the midst of the aftermath of the
October 1973 war in the Middle East when
Kissinger managed to launch one Gosei
a long-lasting peace process still going
on of course in the Middle East by
negotiating disengagement agreements and
and so on and ultimately what I guess
this view about Henry's if we take his
resume he is also a Nobel Peace Prize
winner among other things which I think
we can discuss perhaps later on in some
detail that that particular controversy
but I think George P Shultz who if one
of Kissinger successors put it pretty
succinctly when he he said but there is
only one Henry Kissinger they broke the
mold after they made him he is a unique
man in many ways the first non-american
born Secretary of State the first Jewish
American Secretary of State and indeed
probably the most celebrated of American
foreign policy makers of the Cold War
era but there is also mr. Henry there is
dr. Kissinger and there is mr. Henry
this is of course chekalin Hyde but it's
also actually Kissinger was called mr.
Henry when he went to back to Germany in
after during World War two and he became
part of the occupation forces it was
effectively running a small town in
Germany as a noncommissioned officer and
he insisted everybody calls him mr.
Henry
because Kissinger of course was a German
name he did not want to be associated
with that particular background at the
time in any case there is mr. Henry
which is summarized I think by the
British American journalist Christopher
Hitchens and this is a quote from his
book published a few years ago the trial
of Henry Kissinger which effectively
attempts to cast Kissinger in the role
of a war criminal
and the qualities on lonely impurities
rank it smells to heaven in the name of
innumerable victims known and unknown it
is time to Justice to take a hand and he
is referring here in the book and in the
which is the series of cases if you wish
to the Kissinger's crimes as Hitchens
would argue this one which is his links
to the Pinochet regime in Chile and
there's no question and I get into this
a little bit in the book that from early
on the purpose after Salvador Allende
became the first socialist president of
Chile even before he was born in the
Nixon administration policy was to in
effect get rid of him or at least
undermine him so that he would never be
reelected that was the minimum goal and
his links to authoritarian dictators
particularly in South America have of
course made some headline news lately
when there's some new documents about
Kissinger's license with the Argentinian
military junta roughly about the same
time and so there are also other cases
which itchin stalks about which and
which he argues make Kissinger in effect
guilty of crimes against humanity as he
would put that he was instrumental in
ordering a secret bombing of Cambodia
which resulted in possibly in thousands
of of civilian casualties in Cambodia
after after 1969 there are arguments
that Kissinger and then President Gerald
Ford in 1975 in effect gave the green
light to Indonesia's President Suharto
to go in and take over East Timor which
is just left the Portuguese Empire in
late 1975 resulting in a civil war that
then again resulted that went on for
about 25 years and resulted in estimates
about 200,000 East Timorese being killed
there are all these cases
and and I get into many of these in the
book that seem to indicate what we can
have is mr. Henry who has very few moral
qualms about the little people
what happens to the little guy
particularly if those little guys happen
to be in the so-called third world that
to him what was important was number one
American national security the way he
saw it and of course number two the
reputation of Henry Kissinger which is
the charge that Christopher Hitchens
thumbs up in his in his particular book
so this particular economy this
juxtaposition of these two views of on
the one hand of the Kissinger the sort
of prince of realpolitik who came and in
effect gave American foreign policy a
new purpose in the late 60s and early
70s as the United States was suffering
from the trauma of Vietnam he hope he
went and opened China negotiated the
terms with the Soviet Union negotiated
an end to American involvement in
Vietnam not perhaps the best kind of
event but arguably he negotiated an
agreement that allowed the United States
to bring troops back and so on and he
negotiated the first set of Middle East
agreements after night after the October
1973 war he was super Kay many Newsweek
called him Super K in 1974 after he had
negotiated a second disengagement
agreement that between Israelis and the
Syria Syrians on the other hand it was
always controversial he was known to
have wiretap his own staff he was
suspected of having strong leads to
authoritarian regimes and so on and so
forth so what I tried to do is is figure
out in this book whether one of the two
of these particular views is correct and
I tend to come to the conclusion that
and I sort of start with the premise
that no man is perfect or perfectly evil
and I think with my mic on sort of post
revisionist view of Henry Kissinger is I
think how I might characterize the the
outcome of mine of my research let me
move on to just give you a brief
chronology because one of the reasons I
think why did there are these two polar
opposite views of Henry Kissinger is
that his career in office Hanna saw the
rise and fall scenario that in the early
years of his time in office particular
you could say until the resignation of
Richard Nixon perhaps it seemed to
record a series of diplomatic successes
and particularly in the three areas that
we're the greatest challenges seemed to
the next new Nixon administration when
it came in in January of 1969 and what I
mean by these three is perhaps most
impressively the opening so-called open
into China Kissinger of course becomes
the man who goes to China secretly in
July of 1971 meets with Joanne lie and
then paved the way for a Nixon trip in
February of 1972 and this breaks the ice
that had covered sino-american relations
since the end of the Chinese Civil War
in the late 1940s and it's no wonder
that this achievement is very much one
of the lasting achievements that that
all of the historians god and others who
who indeed hold a favorable view and
even if they don't hold a favorable view
of Henry Kissinger tend to still trumpet
as this one one of his major
achievements making question whether it
depended ultimately on Henry Kissinger
himself or the open in the China would
have happened in any case but certainly
Maharajah he was the right man for that
particular type of operation that took
place during the during the first Nixon
administration
the second achievement
the second challenge of the three major
challenges facing the Nixon
administration was the the Soviet fact
the Soviet Union had amassed a nuclear
arsenal by the late 1960s that was
roughly equal to that of the United
States one of the big questions was what
to do with this the new dilemma how to
orchestrate the new relationship and
what took place ultimately of the the
first major result of the negotiations
in which case we played an instrumental
role was the salt one agreement and the
ABM Treaty that we signed in May of 1972
in Moscow so in other words kissing is
very instrumental in negotiating or
launching the process of the tunt in
soviet-american relations in the in the
early 1970s and in this cartoon what we
see of course is Nixon on the right and
Brezhnev on the Left clinking glasses
celebrating the salt one agreement
signed in Moscow in May of 1972 and what
do you see in the glasses however is
that on Nixon's class perhaps you don't
see it all that well but there's a boat
there's a ship and the text there says
Soviet arms shipments in Brezhnev's
class we have a mine a water mine which
and the text says the u.s. blockade
what is this referring to is that in May
of 1972 the Vietnam War is in a very
perilous face the North Vietnamese had
launched launched their famous Spring
Offensive of 1972 the United States had
responded by blockading North Vietnamese
harbors and the Soviets indeed suffered
some casualties in the process because
they were the major arms suppliers often
North Vietnamese at the time so what the
cartoonist is captured here is the
dilemma of on the one hand the two
superpowers
we're at odds obviously in Vietnam on
the other hand they're clinking their
glasses after the signing of the salt
country and the salt one agreement and
the ABM Treaty and the text underneath
says to peace and I believe we did a
third third achieved in October of 1972
Kissinger went to the came from yet been
negotiating feverishly with the North
Vietnamese particular with Ladakh so who
was seen there shaking hands with
Kissinger in Paris and came in October
of 1972 to the Oval Office and told
Nixon and mr. president you have three
for three
meaning we come to China we've had the
time with the Soviet Union and the salt
one agreement now we have a peace
agreement in Vietnam as it turns out the
peace agreement is eventually all I want
to say have some arms disagreement is
the more accurate phrase is eventually
John signed in Paris in January of 1973
what it provides for is the exit of
American troops from South Vietnam and
the return of American POWs it is not in
the Vietnam War not for one day
and in the end two years later of course
to North Vietnamese launch yet another
offensive which eventually then unites
Vietnam so the third one of the three
the ending of the Vietnam War is
obviously a questionable very
questionable achievement ironically it
is also the achievement for which Henry
Kissinger and LaDuke though are awarded
the Nobel Peace Prize in in October of
1973 and the story of that of course
interesting the doctor refuses the price
says there is no peace why apiece price
Kissinger
except to discredit a few years later
when the North Vietnamese are in Saigon
he does write to the Norwegian Nobel
Committee which is the committee that
Awards two Nobel Peace Prize and says
that well things didn't quite work out
so I would like to return my price the
Norwegians say well you know rules are
rules
you got the price keepeth and so there
we are
but in other words there's already signs
by early 1970 in the beginning of of
Nixon's second term there indeed some of
the diplomatic achievements even if the
tunt is obviously still working out very
well the open-ended China is being
developed there are problems serious
problems and problems that emerge
particularly in what we could call the
third world success as as Vietnam and
these problems become increasingly
obvious in the in the years that follow
still in 1974 and this is one of the
eleven Time magazine covers in which
Henry Kissinger was featured between
1969 19 1975 he disappeared from the
cover after 1975 this is obviously
tribute to his efforts in the Middle
East after the October war their shuttle
diplomacy Kissinger goes into the Middle
East travels between various capitals
between the Israelis to serious the
Israelis the Egyptians the Israelis the
Saudis the Israelis the Jordanians so on
and so forth with the end result that in
1974 he is able to claim two major
achievements in the Middle East a
disengagement agreement between Israel
and Egypt and then later on one between
Israel and Syria and he is very much the
man at the middle of all this he's the
one who's doing the media
between the Arabs and the Israelis and
time is wandering this obviously how
Henry does it he is a magician he's
pulling out these stuffs out of his hat
like a magician the great Kissinger the
text reads on the side he's at the
height of his reputation at this
particular point in time in 1974 now
there are those who would argue that in
fact his efforts in the Middle East are
mainly a way of avoiding being in
Washington in 1973-74 because of
Watergate and because there were rumors
he the question of wiretapping his own
staff and all of this was creating all
sorts of awkward questions from the
press for Henry Kissinger but I think is
he he was at the height of his his
popularity he was actually pulled the
most admired man in America two years in
a row in 1973 and 1974 a year later a
year after the great kissinger how henry
does it too we have this cartoon
dr. Atlas Kissinger a man with the world
on his shoulders and part of the world
suddenly has fallen off we see their
Middle East peace process suddenly stops
there is no disengagement agreement for
example between Israel and Jordan there
is no solution to the Palestinian
question and so on Vietnam and Cambodia
suddenly in the spring of 1975 Commons
victories Vietnam is United Tech Mayer
rules takes over in Cambodia and so on
and so forth
and Kissinger is seen there telling the
now President Gerald Ford that sorry mr.
president it just rolled off the world
is no longer cooperating it seems he's
no longer able to juggle everything in a
way that he had been before so the
question that then obviously emerges if
we have this rise and fall in terms of
kissing his foreign-policy why one of
the reasons wines foreign policy is no
not a complete success and just quickly
go through I think three points that I I
make throughout the book that to me
seemed to so to be the general points
that one can and we can talk perhaps
afterwards about some more specific
questions but the general points that
seem to explain why the keys in the
foreign policy record does see this
particular rise and fall in between 1969
and 1974 1977 the first point is what I
like to call operational flaws and
here's another one of those time
magazine covers Nixon's secret agent
Henry Kissinger
it's from early 1972 now mangu Doggett
is nothing wrong in secret diplomacy if
it produces results produces results and
in kissinger case it did produce
significant results opening the china
salt one agreement and although and
agreement on the economic etcetera it
said the problem is that the way foreign
policy functions in the Nixon
administration in particular in the
Nixon administration means that a lot of
people are being left out of the
decision-making process people that
traditionally would be rather involved
in this process and I'm referring now in
particular to the State Department which
as I understand it tends to have
something to do with the making of
American foreign policy but in the Nixon
administration particularly in the years
1971-72 the State Department is very
much put aside and ignored to a large
extent as Nixon and Kissinger are making
their foreign policy for series of back
channels secret channels to the Soviet
Union to China to Germany to some Middle
Eastern leaders etcetera etcetera and of
course the secret these talks in Paris
with the North Vietnamese
and this sort of secrecy this sort of
operational method certainly is not it
seems to me it's not a way of building a
structure of foreign policy that what
you do is in fact you create a lot of
resentment and you perhaps come up with
series of breakthroughs like the open in
China and so on but is that enough to
guarantee sort of smooth operations
remove the progression of foreign policy
and and relations for example with China
I took these two pictures obviously Bob
we see Kissinger and Nixon discussing in
on Air Force one discussing some issues
of foreign policy below we see Kissinger
with Alexander Haig who was his deputy
for a long period of time and indeed one
of those few who was actually deeply
involved in many of these back-channel
operations during the during the Nixon
administration so operational flaws the
second point
domestic politics domestic conundrums if
there's anything that Henry Kissinger
did not connect with it is the American
domestic political arena and I think
that maybe has something to do with his
European background but certainly has to
do with his penchant for real politic
and is often very open statements about
real politic that national security the
American national interest matters more
than ideas human rights and things of
that nature
and that's one thing the other thing of
course is Watergate and this is linked
to the to my first point about
operational force particularly the
question of secrecy in 73-74 the cartoon
here by the way it will indicate this is
at the time then Kissinger is going to
the Middle East to negotiate
disengagement agreements and and so on
and so forth
you see Nixon here in the Oval Office
bidding farewell to Kissinger is going
on one of his John's to do the middle
east and thing and hurry back Kissinger
I'd like you to make a bit of peace
around here at home which is obviously
unable to do but but Nixon is very much
in 73-74 being bombarded by various
requests of the Watergate tapes and then
so on and so forth his credibility
collapses completely long before he
actually resigns in August of 1974 and
that when a president's credibility
collapses and when foreign policy was
based on this was sort of a two-man show
up to that in in the Nixon
administration it certainly creates
problem for the other guy who was a non
elected official in trying to run
foreign policy so gives and certainly
suffers in that sense over Nixon's
demise on the other hand his reputation
actually source is the only remaining
he's the one left over often external
mission who continues high-level left
over of the Nixon administration who
continues into the for administration he
is very much viewed as the one stable
force by the general public the trust in
his foreign policy leadership some
extent increases ironically as Nixon's
Nixon's goes down but this doesn't mean
that the questions about his operational
methods
I'm not linked to questions of Watergate
secrecy backchannels wiretapping I've
almost Watergate all about break-ins and
so on
dirty tricks etc there is a link let's
draw so Kissinger is is clearly also
implicated if not as a sort of
conspira-con conspirator in the in this
the domestic side of of Watergate but
his operational method made this do you
come under question and this is
something that makes him an issue then
in 1976 in the presidential election of
1976 in Jimmy Carter and Ronald Reagan
the two major contenders Richard for
both make it an issue in the 1976
election thirdly perhaps most
importantly the flawed design what I
mean by the flawed design is the actual
foreign policy architect of Henry
Kissinger and put very simply
the foreign policy was designed by and
large to serve traditional American
called for ends but the problem in 1969
of course was that you could not simply
could not for example think about even
think about sending American troops
abroad to fight communism in fact you
had to bring them back so the way I see
Kissinger sort of grand policy approach
to and from the main reasons why he
pursues the tant why he pursues the
opening to China and so on
he's as a way of fighting the Cold War
containing the Soviets in particular
through diplomacy rather than that than
through other means and there's the
other point about is that his foreign
policy is very much also based on the
assumption that the Soviet Union is and
will remain the one primary adversary'
of the United States for a long period
of time and it is the one power that
needs to be contained and what that
means is that in the period in the 1970s
what we see is in many ways dramatic
transformations in the so-called third
world with the end of the Vietnam War
with fine final decolonization or for
example the Portuguese Empire and in the
book I talk about the Angolan Civil War
in which the United States gets involved
through various covert covert means but
the whole purpose of these engagements
is not to to cater to to these
structural changes that are taking place
in the third world whether it's in
Africa whether it's in the forest
whether it's in in Latin America rather
it's still based on a fairly
straightforward fairly simplistic I
would argue cold war logic which sees
the world in a bipolar fashion I know
there are lots
talk about Nixon Kissin thinkin about
five centers of power and all the rest
of it I don't see that in the actual
policymaking as being a significant
factor they're still thinking in terms
of is that for example if he takes the
Middle East and the cartoon here is the
last time magazine cover in which
Kissinger is feature we see various
Middle East leaders in in the background
in the Middle East when Kissinger gets
involved in the peace process
his main purpose is not peace in the
Middle East for pieces sake it's to get
the Soviets out of the Middle East and
he succeeds in that he succeeds in the
fact that Soviet the Soviet Union is no
longer the main supporter of Egypt or
Syria after after the period of shuttle
diplomacy now but it doesn't of course
bring peace to the Middle East it does
not take into account a very specific
local context say in the Middle East
which includes most importantly of
course the Palestinian question which
still today remains pretty much
unresolved so in that sense since there
is no one of the basic problems with
with kissing's foreign policy is that it
is fairly it is not all that in the
innovative it is not all that innovative
in terms of actually thinking about the
world in a different manner than other
American foreign policy leaders had done
before 1969 but simply to choose a
different different set of tools if you
wish to practice similar goals as have
been practiced by previous
administrations after that so
operational flaws domestic conundrums
flawed basically flawed design in terms
of of the overall foreign policy all of
these together then made me call the
book
as Jim indicated the flawed architect
and that's it I'm gonna let you see
field his own question since it's easier
with the microphone um if you could just
identify yourself if you asked a
question that would be great then he
knows with whom he is speaking and we've
got plenty of time so misty little sure
I have two brief questions of mr.
Shawcross has argued that the agreement
ending the war in Vietnam was one that
Nixon and Kissinger must have known
would after be what despite their
dislike for an elegant bug-out
essentially lead to the downfall of
South Vietnam
once American troops were pulled out and
the role of the the events that leading
to the in Turkish invasion of Cyprus I
think have not really been gone into the
detail that they deserve and there is a
school of thought which I personally
agree that with that the Colonel's would
never have invaded Cyprus if Kissinger
had not despised macario's and that he
must have given a green light to the the
overthrow of macario's by Nico Sampson
thanks yeah
Vietnam there is the way I I see the
Vietnam a grim and the way if you read
the record of negotiations not just
between both internal documents with in
between Nixon and Kissinger and and so
on but also negotiations between
Kissinger and the Chinese Kissinger
embers always the two countries that are
the main supporters of the North
Vietnamese and also some some of the
talks between Kissinger and even Ladakh
thought the point that comes across
constantly is after 1971 I think there's
a shift in strategy
after at around 1971 at around the
opening the China basically saying that
what we want what the United States
wants is what's called the decent
interval in other words what they want
is to have an agreement that would allow
for the United States to remove its
remaining troops but as Kissinger put
for example to do Gromyko at one point
the the Soviet foreign minister if a
week after American troops leave if the
North Vietnamese suddenly invade South
Vietnam then we would have to do
something we couldn't just let it be but
if there is a period of time and there
is because an evolution of the situation
internal situation within Vietnam then
it would be very very unlikely that the
United States would actually intervene
so that would support people what you
indicate the argument that there is
certainly as a sort of general view
what's important is to get out and
what's important is to get out with not
too much loss of face it's not to say
I'm not what I'm not saying is that
there is no hope of the situation the
division lingering on and so on and
Nixon was certainly keen on using not
sending American troops anymore but
certainly using firepower bombings and
all the rest of it for as long as it
took to keep the interval to keep the
situation from collapsing and in some
ways war negate removes his authority
next impossible to to continue bombing
in in Indochina etc but in any case the
the idea that Vietnam would be unified
under the North Vietnamese is not it
certainly something that is considered
as it as an option that it's not going
to it's an acceptable option in the long
run
in during the negotiations of 1972 and
1973 now I hope that answers that with
that question the other one the Turkish
invasion of Cyprus I think the broader
point there and a little bit to this in
in the book but not not very much on the
particular case of Turkey I think what
we have and this goes and it back to the
the flawed design part of the flawed
design
I say flawed anyway is the great
emphasis put on stability around the
world and particularly in what is
considered third world countries and
potential countries that might somehow
end up in the wrong camp and this is
something that comes is evident in
kisses dealings with various Latin
American leaders whether is the Chileans
or Argentinians or others it's also
evident one could I think in the case of
of both the the well dealing with the
Turks as well as dealing with the
Colonel's in in in Greece that that it's
for somehow somehow there's perspective
cases in cases perspective the stability
that an authoritarian regime can bring
is certainly much preferable to the
instability that would come through some
sort of a left-wing government being in
power say in in Greece and of course
macario's is viewed as as being very
much sort of on the left-hand and death
take also in the country some national
security considers in terms of this is
taking place at the same time I asked
you series shuttling in the Middle East
trying to promote the peace process of
various disengagement agreements with
with Middle East leaders
okay what if everybody would like to
comment on this agenda CSE conference on
Security Corporation Europe it seems to
me that if we are talking about the
flaws of the Dhamma statistics a prime
example actually top of the list there
is a diamond to be made of the diplomacy
label to there're too much power and too
personalized traversing our president
then I think it is to be done by
referring to the server Faragher
appreciate the importance and
effectiveness of this means part of the
fancy very different from
being traded and that he admired so is
it so I mean wasn't just at the
beginning that he was available
appreciated or as it seems to me he
never really didn't there's me try to
answer this there's a great irony
distances approach to the CSCE its no
interest in the details none whatsoever
once he commented you can write it in
Swahili
for all I care and I don't think too
many people actually very few people
actually cut through the whole document
even you know Kissinger know but even
within his staff and so it's massive
docking took several years to negotiate
of course negotiators in Geneva in
Helsinki and and so on and so forth and
we have the three baskets the famous
free basket about basket three being the
most important that you refer to human
rights and recognition that human rights
ultimately are part of security and in
other words human security was part of
the overall European security
arrangement I think that's the major
legacy of of the Helsinki of course even
in in many ways he had no interest in
these particular details however he was
actually instrumental in getting the
Soviets to agree to a number of these
these concessions including the fact
that you could actually change borders
within Europe nonviolent and this is
quote become extremely important after
1989 when Germany is its unified and the
Soviets opposed this almost to the very
end until Kissinger and Gromyko the
Soviet foreign minister negotiated on
several cases in the spring of 1975 and
Gromyko finally gave him the other thing
gives also pushed once various points in
in in in so-called basket three they
talk about free
things about freedom of information and
and so on this was still on the table
after several years of negotiations and
you say ultimately yes he did push them
now why is he pushing it because he was
under pressure from his European allies
to do something and of course the period
in the mid nineteen seventies is a very
tricky period within transatlantic
relations so Kissinger some extent views
this as a way of modifying his West
European critics critics that become
increasingly what became critical in the
aftermath of the Middle East war the oil
crisis Kissinger was talking about the
year of Europe and at one point in 1973
and all the rest of them so four kisses
at CSC to some extent is a way of
healing transatlantic relations is that
he's not viewing it as a treaty and it's
not really a tree it's it's a set of
agreements that will transform Eastern
Europe and yet he's instrumental in the
actual agreement in the process that
leads to the actual game and I think
that's the great paradox it's you know
it's an accidental but what happens
afterwards of course and this is under
some debate but but certainly the
Helsinki of course allow for various
human rights organizations to claim
certain legitimacy in Eastern Europe and
Soviet Union and you know we could list
the number of people that become famous
later on like vaclav havel for example
in in Czechoslovakia who who I to more
freely not completely freely but more
freely as a result in the aftermath of
the Helsinki agreements should we thank
Kissinger for all this no but he
certainly he was ironically and
paradoxically he did his bit to advance
the transformation of Eastern Europe but
he actually admit one of the things he
admits to in his the third volume of his
memoirs is that he had very little
interest in the process and that this
was something that yes later on is
historic but at the time seemed seemed
like just a showcase of of diplomacy sir
first question would you say that dr.
Kissinger is the last strategic thinker
we've had in the area of foreign affairs
that all the people that have come after
him have been vaguely tactical type
people that's the first question and the
second do you think you can make any
progress in great changes except in
secret the reason I say that if you look
at some of the issues going on today in
the Korean situation and the Iran
situation as soon as that becomes public
you have all these different forces and
and then it becomes very difficult to
make any progress because the susi try
to move in the one direction you have
all those countervailing forces from the
other directions so those are the two
questions I have thank you
we try out the second question first I
think two dilemma what the justification
for secrecy that was twofold at the time
it was to insulate the big decisions
from the ROC Radek nonsense to get lost
in the bureaucracy to become the
universe if you wanted to make big
changes the argument goes you had to
have a few very select group of people
working on this particular great success
the opening to China
and anytime you involves a new an added
group of people something most likely to
go wrong there would be and particularly
this there would be leaks to the press
and of course the press kissing has a
very curious relationship with the press
but the concern was that
that there would be all sorts of
domestic pressures from the press there
would be criticism this could lead the
opener china was of course a potentially
very controversial issue it raised the
question of how about the US relations
with Taiwan what what will happen to
that long-standing US commitment and of
course that commitment sort of it begins
to evaporate because that's the that's
the payoff in effect that the Chinese
are demanding and this could have
domestic political repercussions and it
does because what you have is Ronald
Reagan goes bananas at one point that's
a Buchanan who is Nixon speechwriter
almost physically attacks Kissinger on
the way back from from China in February
of 1972 claim that he has sold time on
count down the down the river its
so-called Shanghai commonly care and so
on and I think this would increase I
would imagine the belief four kisses yes
you meet sick you need to be secretly
you need to insulate yourself from the
distractions of domestic politics the
problem is you can't do that certainly
if you want long-term success is it's
very difficult you can have these flashy
flashy diplomatic successes such as the
open in the China but it's very
difficult to build the sort of long term
foreign policy purely on on secrecy now
just one added point I think this is
certainly created an operational model
which was then later on followed
particularly in China policy by a number
of his his successors and one example
would be 1989 after Tiananmen Square
what we have is a secret trip by Brent
Scowcroft and and Larry Eagleburger both
of course
Kissinger's former aides to China to try
to improve the relationship because
there's obviously a lot of criticism in
the United States after Tiananmen Square
in 1989 so in the late fall of of of 89
the two men go secretly China and so on
so we created a certain kind of
operational model that the subsequent
administration's do follow now what seed
the last which is a thinker I don't
think so
and sometimes I doubt whether he really
was a strategic thinker I think he was
very good with tactics he was an
excellent negotiator it's fun actually
to read some of these documents he has a
great sense of humor and timing when it
comes down to negotiating particularly
with with Soviet leaders with the
Chinese who sometimes misses humor and
the North Vietnamese who always misses
humor but but he has a great sort of
he's an excellent negotiator business I
think there's no question about it he
knows how to and I think what it
actually is he knows how to put himself
in the other guys shoes so he knows what
they would like to hear and there's
problems with that in the long term of
course because you end up telling a lot
of half-truths and all the rest of it
but but it's sort of in the ending in
the short term it usually does produce
sometimes very remarkable successes in
in terms of negotiations I'm well so you
think I think within the book current
Bush administration there has been
plenty of specific thinking certainly
after 9/11 and before that asked to
America's role in the world that in many
ways is much more comprehensive than
what you would find in the Nixon
administration and with Henry Kissinger
in in the late 60s and early 70s and
that perhaps not a satisfactory answer
but no I don't think so I don't think he
was the last great strategic thinker yes
close the question is that we had found
ourselves with an enemy of the Russian
and an enemy of the Chinese for the
possibility of them uniting at some
point down the road against us and try
to fracture that potential viewing in
between China and Russia and and get
more diplomacy going with both of them
that terms of strategy yeah now the
point about that though is that he
didn't have to do any fracturing the
Chinese in the Soviet almost went to war
in the spring of 1969 and that created
an opening for the United States and the
challenge then later on was to indeed
manipulate that fracture in a way that
the Chinese and the Soviets would never
combine again if the sino-soviet
alliance that has been the great fear of
the United States in the 1950s in
particular the dab would not be reborn I
don't think there was much I mean when
you think about it this probably wasn't
all that much danger of that particular
Alliance getting back together in any
case but I I think that was the that was
the challenge wasn't actually to to
fracture the Alliance in the first place
that took care that the Americans had
missed in fact previous administrations
had missed already the great tension
between China and Beijing that the
emerge is already in the late 1950s sir
basic premises and the architect the
father the architect hisses your work in
the White House but it wasn't the master
of the White House and I could easily
see you know the president have a
different view of bode architect was and
I'm sure you get into it in your book
but I was wondering if you could talk a
little bit more to hear about that
relationship maybe also in the area of
tactics but strategy and tactics and
because Nixon himself certainly viewed
himself as an architect in there and a
strategist the the Nixon gets into
relationship I think is one of the most
complicated almost scary sometimes
to sort of witness and to go through the
mixture of both dependence on each other
I mean to begin with Kissinger would be
a nobody without Nicks if Nixon did not
choose him as his national security
adviser give him all the leeway give him
all the trust in the end that would
amend that case I could never have for
example gone to China secretly in July
of 1971
so Kissinger certainly depends on on
Nixon a great deal and awesome you know
his position because he after all was
the president of the United States Nixon
I think had very to the broad I just
think about Graham strategy he had broad
ideas about how how the world had
changed and and the fact that the
american-soviet relationship for example
had gone through a change dramatically
he was the one who talked about the five
power centers which included the United
States Soviet Union China Europe and
Japan so he had this in essence a fairly
straightforward simplistic perhaps grand
strategy in mind when he was not the guy
who was going to go and implement it in
the end and he was also Nixon's primary
concern it seems to me and I may be
wrong on this
he certainly wanted to be a great
foreign policy presence but he squared
his concern his greatest doubt was
always about domestic acceptance which
is what leads him to Watergate of course
and foreign policy is a tool to a large
extent of winning domestic acceptance in
the United States and he's a successful
tool if you think about the 1972
election where he wins by a landslide
despite the fact that Vietnam is still
still on he has in a sense made himself
into a statesman with
Kissinger's help what happens after it's
the problem that because Nixon is
self-destructing the self-destructive
through Watergate
he is also Kissinger emerges as the
frontman of foreign policy so that
relation also changed because of the
particular domestic domestic context now
the other the many features in the West
I think just one other one that that's
that I find extremely entertaining
perhaps in a sort of scary kind of way
is the jealousy that that Nixon in
particular has over over Kissinger one
of Kissinger strengths is that he can
actually deal with the press in a way
that Nixon is unable to do he can make
himself available if he wants to he can
leak as he said you know if anybody in
the administration leaks about foreign
policy going to be me so he leaves he
knows how to leak he knows how to
cultivate the press the rights reporters
and so on he knows how to build an image
Nixon doesn't know how to do that and he
the the amount of conversations
telephone calls that you find with Nixon
trying to find out from Kissinger how
certain columnists and journalists are
going to write about
his speeches about Vietnam his endless
speeches about Vietnam for example this
book let me give you one example this is
in leading in May of of 19 1971 and
Mixon is given a speech on Vietnam and
then he Kissinger also likes to
cultivate Nixon don't you know he knows
how to play the courtier and he knows
how to how to get points from from Nixon
and make himself indispensable and so on
so you think also greatest speech mr.
president you know never you know not a
dry eye in the house and all the rest of
it and it is well would you like me to
see what Joe Allsop is thinking about it
and mixers no no I don't you know I
don't care about that I don't care about
that crap as he puts it so ten minutes
later only 15 minutes later Nixon calls
Kissinger and say well did you talk to
ourselves
and Kissinger is some cocktail party or
whatever and say well actually yet but
I'll get right back to you and then you
know he calls back a few minutes later
saying yes he thinks this was a
wonderful wonderful speech I'm not sure
if he actually had spoken with also up
at the time but and so this goes on and
on so in at one level Kissinger actually
becomes Nixon's press secretary and and
sort of controlling his particular
relationship with the press and that is
a very powerful tool that ultimately
will drive mixer nuts
but makes them dependent in a sense of
of Kissinger in yet another way so so
there is that that that great dependency
that it's a very very curious yes/no
could have been or should have been a
more sophisticated brand strategy so my
question is this what would in a more
sophisticated Brennan strategy and how
do you know that that whatever it is
that you have in mind
more sophisticated grand strategy would
also have been a wiser friend strategy
well that's obviously it's it's a
question I cannot give you a foolproof
answer to if
I think what is missing in the in the
next Nixon Kissinger approach it's
certainly a sort of concern about well
what for example were they raised
earlier which is the CSC human rights
issues of that nation and these are very
fundamental facts fundamental
characteristics
you could argue of the United States and
of the view that the United States likes
to project the broad about itself and I
think this is not them it's not just
pure rhetoric I think it does have a
genuine impact on how then other
countries relate to the United States
there is and that the particular fact is
is clearly missing from from from
kissing's approach there is no
significant concern also on large parts
of the world parts of the world that
today still see as being in turmoil and
some of which will become genuine also
the genuine in genuine crisis and it's
very little interest in Africa for
example there is Middle East becomes
interesting because it's an opportunity
to knock the Soviets out of the Middle
East in essence in the China is
interesting as long as there are
American troops there but then it
becomes uninteresting I think if the
United States is was to be the global
power they should have been much more
comprehensive approach to American
foreign policy in this period and
premise in part on the fact that there
has been a significant erosion of
American power and therefore in part the
United States is operating out of
weakness and that it's a sense of how do
you sort of yeah and I think the a that
the policy answer that was so-called
Nixon Doctrine the idea that because you
know basic idea the United States does
not have the power to send troops abroad
it cannot for domestic reasons for other
reasons engage in another Vietnam and
there's no way the United States can
protect military power in that way
abroad so how do we protect the American
power abroad and one of the answers to
that is that we find strong regional
allies that will in effect pursue
policies that are in line of American
interests the problem with that is that
most of these strong regional allies
tend to be authoritarian regimes some of
them destined to complete collapse such
as Iraq on the way back from Moscow
summit in May of 1972 next nagisa stop
by in Tehran and they in effect offer
the shah the sort of look they don't
offer him actual military aid but they
tell him you know he can buy as much
military hardware in effect from the
united states as as he wants to the wide
are they calling the show in this way
because he will through the show through
a strong militarily strong iran they
believe that we're going to have a more
stable middle east the other strong
regional ally is of course israel which
also getting a great deal of of actual
military aid at this at this point from
the united states now i think i mean
this this is to rely on the show on
other types of authoritarian regimes ask
your proxies in specific regions because
you cannot simply protect your military
power there
clearly leads to a much worse situation
in the long run and in the case of the
show it doesn't take even I mean it's a
matter of a few years when we have the
revolution and so on so I think what is
lacking is is the sort of understanding
about fundamentals of grassroots change
that is taking place in many parts of
what was known and still is known I
guess the so-called third world I think
that was the major between equality
strategic miscalculation and a blank
spot in effect in this in this
particular particular approach I'm not
sure what the actual answer would have
been and I think that is admittedly
that's and I don't know if there was an
answer to that specific dilemma but it
seems that particular approach taken
certainly did not improve for example
the situation in the Middle East in a in
a significant you need to get work yes
the Department of State and the risk of
sinking into historiographical detail
I'd like to ask a question about
sourcing which you mentioned in your
introduction up there right at the time
you were coming to press these and
because in your telephone conversation
of transition became available to the
National Archives and you mentioned how
on your examination of these that you
felt that they basically supported your
conclusions but added some because of
wonderful color but I'd like to raise an
example where I think actually the
telephone transcripts an instant to tape
recordings actually in a lot of ways to
change the way you look at the the
documents the formal documents as they
exist in the files and I think this is
the way that wouldn't be that surprising
for the administration that that
practice secret diplomacy I didn't want
to write down something on the paper if
someone else would find out what they
were doing but these informal
record-keeping measures that they took
recorded these things anyway and this is
in the in the spring of 1972 and you
talk about the crisis having to do with
with the North Vietnamese invasion of
South and you talk about Moscow summon
but the other part of that as William
Munny points out in his book is the
ratification debate in Germany and that
this was a key part of the Soviet
foreign policy and this captain come up
right at the time when all these things
were were in play and this was something
that Nixon and Kissinger had fallen to
their lab that they were then they they
then used they manipulated to try to get
the Soviets to help them in India and
you don't find that at all
in the documents but you find that in
the telephone transcripts and you find
that in the tape recordings and if I'm
not mistaken when I looked at your
treatment at that period we don't talk
about the ratification debate at all but
I do think it's a key element and all
that and if for instance if it's really
bryon barely defeated that vote of
no-confidence
but those p d--'s usually could have
gone down or the Soviets could have
cancelled the summit in the midst of
this crisis in which case things look a
lot different than
they eventually worked out I wonder if
you would comment I'm not exactly sure
what what you want me to comment I mean
this obviously there's linkage between
linkage is a famous word but there's
linkage between the germinal situation
and Vietnam yeah in the that's the thing
as a sort of how they're different than
other sources that you able to look at
how they might change the way you can
look at things but then that a specific
example of being that case of 2072 in
german ratification yeah yeah there is
no question that when you actually get
to listen to tapes when you hear the
actor speaking but then you really get
to the it's almost scary and this thesis
you're not able to do this in much of
the research that start historians do
you're not able to actually sort of
eavesdrop in the conversations between
the fearless Nixon and Kissinger or and
and so on and so forth so that is I mean
it's it's it's amazing when you
sometimes you can compare then the
transcripts which of course there were
transcripts often made of these
conversations and you do find some
detail missing and certainly you don't
get the tone of the voice which can
often often have a lot of sort of adds
the the and certainly flavor if you if
you do it that way to the actual actual
situation now in terms of so point being
that yes if there's no question that the
tapes the White House tapes the the
Kissinger tapes and Nixon tapes and all
the rest of it they are invaluable
source material they're not the only
source material of course that one can
use and there are lots of stuff that's
that's missing from if your only base
would base your research on listening to
the Nixon White House tapes I think
you've come across with the
with another type of rather distorted
view of of how things things operate
because of not for money not everything
was recorded then and for another thing
Nixon also yes he worked the phone a lot
but he was the kind of leader who didn't
really like to confront people face to
face so he tickly in the first few years
he would write his orders on various
memos he was sent various reports and so
on so he would example on the side of a
memo right K for Kissinger do this do
that
and send it to send it back but so so
there's a variety of of source material
clearly available and I think one of the
things about this particular period is
there's so much material nowadays and
more and more coming out as you very
well know that it's sometimes hard to
actually decipher what what is what is
important out of out of all of this and
how to choose or have what to leave out
what to include and and so on so that
it's becoming increasingly increasingly
difficult in in that sense the mountain
of material and it also allows of course
various different kinds of
interpretations of events because
there's undoubtedly in various these in
many of these conversations you you do
get statements that seem completely
outrageous when you when you hear them
but maybe just made as a pun or clever
and so so it's it's sometimes it's hard
to hard to sort of decipher fact from
what is really important in this case
now the linkage between Vietnam and
Germany yes I mean there's no no
question that that there is to some
extent to ratification debate and all of
that it it it is covered it sort of
hangs over over the situation in the
spring of 1972 and that there are two
issues in in fact which
which put the may 1972 summit and
between the Soviets and the Americans
into some jeopardy but I think Vietnam
is the number one issue that that is the
issue that mostly that that for the most
but but certainly if if Germany if the
various German treaties would not have
been ratified and all the rest of it
there would have been a great deal of
that this would have certainly derailed
the process okay the school has another
event right after this one I want to
make sure people have time to go visit
the book table and if you do buy a book
I want to make sure that you see still
here to sign one for you so just want to
thank you all for attending and again
congratulate our author here for
produced
you see Hana Maki is an international
history and politics professor at the
Graduate Institute of international